so I'm Justin Cheung I'm a mechanical
engineer working the MIT biomimetics
robotics laboratory and we built the
Hermes humanoid robot which is a
disaster relief robot that is designed
to operate in human design environments
such the Fukushima nuclear reactor the
way you control this robot is the
operator gets into a suit that has
encoders on every joints and when the
human makes it makes an movement the
robot exactly mimic this action and the
only problem with this is that say the
human wants to throw a punch the robot
is exactly constrained to the speed of
the human and we want to take advantage
of the full the full advantage of the
capabilities of the motors and to do
this we're using commute machine
learning techniques to look at what kind
of actions indicate that a human wants
to perform a certain action such as a
punch so the idea is that we can monitor
the initial the initial movements that
became in recognize that the human wants
to throw a punch and then transition
seamlessly into an automated optimized
action and therefore use the full full
capabilities of our motors